okay so hi everybody so this is a talk
about the paper bit complexity of Jordan
normal form and polynomial spectral
factorization
and this is based on joint work with
papri day ravikandan and Nick Ryder
so here's an outline of the talk so I'll
start by telling you what polynomial
spectral factorization is and it's
essentially a type of positivity circuit
for Matrix value univariate polynomials
uh then I'll tell you what Jordan normal
form is
and it turns out this is this will this
is the key ingredient to getting an
efficient algorithm for polynomial
spectral factorization
uh and then I'll tell you
um our algorithmic result for Jordan
Roman forum and the key condition number
estimate that goes into the proof
and finally I'll end with some open
questions about all of these things
there are lots of open questions
okay so let's begin by recalling a
positivity certificate that we're all
maybe familiar with
and that is for univariate polynomials
so suppose I have a monic non-negative
uh univariate polynomial of degree 2D
over the reals
then there's a certificate of this
positivity namely I can write P of X as
Q Bar x times Q of X for some polynomial
complex polynomial Q of degree D and
here bar is just a complex conjugate so
this is certainly positive because the
right hand side is a complex number
times its conjugated so this is a
positivity certificate
and the proof of this is is very simple
well if if P has if p is non-negative on
the real axis
then uh all of its real Roots have even
degree and so for each of those real
Roots you put one fact you just take one
factor and put it in q
and then the rest of the roots
uh are complex and they come in
conjugate pairs
and so we simply take Q of x to include
all of the complex roots in the upper
half plane along with those you know
real roots that we chose in the in the
first step
okay
another positivity certificate you might
be familiar with is for matrices so if
you have a positive semi-definite Matrix
n by n Matrix
then um it has a true ASCII
factorization so you can write it as Q
star Q where Q is a complex n by n
Matrix and uh star is the adjoint
actually in this case you can even take
Q to be real
so uh it turns out there's a very nice
generalization of these facts common
generalization to the setting of Matrix
polynomials uh discovered by rosenblatt
and um I don't remember who HL is uh in
1958
um and this is what this is called
polynomial Spectrum spectral
factorization or Matrix fire each
factorization
so here's the statement if you have a
matrix polynomial P of x
so that's an N by n Matrix whose entries
are polynomials and let's say it's a
degree 2D and it's monic so the leading
term if you write it as uh if you write
it as a polynomial with Matrix solid
coefficients is the identity
so let's say you have such a polynomial
with real coefficients and let's suppose
you know that it's positive
semi-definite for all X so this
polynomial whenever you plug in a real X
is positive seven definite
then the conclusion is that you can
cholesky factorize this at the level of
polynomials namely there there is some
complex polynomial Q of X which is an n
n by n Matrix polynomial of degree d
such that you can write P of X as Q star
x times Q of X where Q star X means you
take the adjoint of all the coefficients
of that Matrix polynomial
so this is now a positivity certificate
because if you plug in a real X the
right hand side is actually the chalesky
factorization of B
so this was originally discovered and
the motivation was related to control
theory uh and it's it has it has a lot
of uses in dynamical systems and the way
we became interested in it is it's the
key ingredient in in one of the proofs
of the health in vinikov theorem in
geometry of polynomials
so the algorithmic question about about
this theorem is well if I give you a p
of x if I give you some integer P of X
can you compute this uh this Q of X
that's a positivity certificate
so that's the question that we're going
to focus on for now the algorithmic
question and let me briefly review
what's known about this so this has been
studied quite a bit over the past few
decades and and there are many uh
constructive methods for finding this
queue
so some some you know important ones are
there's a reduction to solving a
semi-definite program
there's a reduction to Computing the
roots of a polynomial there's a
reduction to Computing the sure form of
a matrix and then there's a reduction to
Computing the Jordan normal form of a
matrix and that last one is due to
gothwork Lancaster and Rodman from 1980.
all right so these are very nice results
but the downside is that they all
require us to solve each of these
problems exactly for example solving an
STP exactly or Computing a Jordan normal
form exactly and none of these things
can actually be done exactly on a on a
computer in a finite number of bit
operations so actually these results
don't give a provable polynomial time
algorithm for this problem
and so the first theorem of this work
called theorem a is a polynomial time
algorithm for this problem so the
theorem says there's an algorithm
which does the following so given a
matrix polynomial P of x uh with
Dimension n by n and degree 2D
and real coefficients that are actually
now integer with a bit entry so I'm
going to use this notation you know
bracket a at the end uh I'm going to use
notation uh bracket parentheses a to to
denote that every entry of this Matrix
polynomial P of X so every entry of
every coefficient
has a bits and is an integer so suppose
I'm given an a bit integer Matrix
polynomial
then the algorithm computes some Matrix
polynomial Q Prime of X such that Q
Prime is close to Q is used to the True
Q in the spectral factorization up to
some Epsilon times the norm where this
Norm is just the entry-wise maximum of
all the coefficients that appear in the
polynomial
so to either compute an approximation of
the the the polynomial Matrix the
polynomial spectral factorization or
certify that knows that no such spectral
factorization exists so if you give it a
polynomial that's not positive
semi-refinant on the real line it will
certify that
and the running time is polynomial in D
the dimension of the D the degree and
the dimension of the matrices a the
number of bits in the matrices and log
one over Epsilon and so the running time
is given here so this is I mean it's not
a very small running time
uh it's it's roughly D to the six n to
the sixth uh but
um you know at some concrete running
time for this problem
okay
so I won't tell you the full proof of
this theorem the analysis is is
basically there's a it contains two
components one is a robust analysis of
this reduction to Jordan normal form due
to God for Lancaster and Rodman and the
other component is an improved algorithm
for Jordan normal form so I'll spend the
rest of the talk telling you what that
improved algorithm is
and once we get that algorithm that that
gives us crma
okay so what is Jordan normal form
so Jordan normal form is a normal form
for square uh let's say complex matrices
and it's the following fact if you have
a square complex Matrix and by n it's
similar to a direct sum of Jordan blocks
where Jordan block with eigenvalue
Lambda is a matrix that looks like this
it has lambdas on the diagonal and ones
on the super diagonal
so uh in particular if you have a
diagonalizable matrix then then the
Jordan normal form all of the Jordan
blocks are size one
and this is a diagonalization is a
special case of this and The Columns of
the similarity V that appear in the
Jordan normal form are um generalized
eigenvectors of the Matrix a
so this appears in many many settings
um for example an applied method it's
relevant in dynamical systems and
theoretical computer science uh it shows
up when you're trying to study the
non-backtracking Matrix
um which is how I learned about it and
in in algebra it shows up in lots of
different ways for example the Jordan
Chevalier decomposition of an algebra
so that's the Jordan normal form
the algorithmic question we'll study is
uh given an integer n Bion Matrix a with
little a bits per entry so again I'm
using this notation with the uh bracket
parentheses
so given an integer Matrix and some
desired accuracy Epsilon I would like to
compute some J Prime and V Prime which
are close to the to a true Jordan normal
form VJ of this Matrix so that's shown
here and let's say the norm is operator
Norm
and this is the forward error
formulation of the problem means given
an input I would like to compute
something which is close to the exact
output for that input
some remarks on this problem so you
can't compute this exactly because well
in particular involves Computing the
eigenvalues uh one feature that makes it
challenging is that the output is
discontinuous in input so if you have a
matrix with let's say you know if you
have a matrix which has some Jordan
blocks of size greater than one
uh in general if you perturb it even
infinites movie you'll get something
with a matrix that has different Jordan
blocks
and this is not a solved problem even in
practice if you try to use standard
computer algebra computer
algebra or just numerical packages to
compute this it's pretty slow even for
100 by 100 Matrix
so the goal now is to have a approval
algorithm for approximately Computing
this Jordan normal form in the sense of
forward error in polynomial number of
bit operations
so what's known about this so there are
roughly two lines of work so the first
one is in the symbolic computation
community
so the highlights are the work of
caltafen at all in 1986 ozello 1987 and
culminating this theorem of guys
practice in 1995.
and uh
what what this line of work ultimately
was able to prove is that given a matrix
a you can compute you can compute some
kind of symbolic representation of the
Jordan normal form so you can uh you can
compute V as an element of a certain
field extension in the eigenvalues of
the Matrix using roughly n to the Omega
exact arithmetic operations so I'm using
the star to suppress logarithmic factors
in n and a
um
uh you can compute this in roughly
matrix multiplication time but it's
that's the number of exact arithmetic
operations and you must be given the
exact eigenvalues in this uh there's a
model of computation where you can be
given some complex numbers which are the
exact eigenvalues
so this is very satisfying because
that's that's a very good bound but it
doesn't give any bit complexity because
uh we actually care about Boolean
operations so how many bits needed to
store the numbers Etc and of course it
assumes that you're given the exact
eigenvalues
so nonetheless there's an important the
ideas in this work are very important
for what I'm going to say uh this
algorithm is based on a very nice idea
which is related to something called the
frobenius canonical form so
a key idea that appears in these proofs
is
um that I mean it's a fact that every
integer Matrix
is similar to a direct sum of companion
matrices that's called the frobenius
canonical form so it's not the Jordan
normal form but it's some other kind of
canonical form
and
to remind you what is a companion Matrix
so why we univariate polynomial of
degree n as shown here with coefficients
Ai and let's say the leading coefficient
is one
then the companion Matrix is an explicit
Matrix shown on the right here whose
characteristic polynomial is equal to to
that univariate polynomial and the
coefficients of the universe polynomial
appear as entries in the companion
Matrix so for Venus canonical form is a
statement that every integer Matrix is
similar to direct term of companion
matrices and the nice thing about this
is it does you don't need to compute
eigenvalues this can be computed exactly
without any error
in polynomial time
okay so that's that's the symbolic uh
computation Community historical
computer science Community there's an
important theorem there's only one
result about this it's an important
theorem of PSI from 1994. and what he
showed is that given an a bit integer
and by matrix you can compute a forward
approximation of the Jordan normal form
in polynomial time so the degree of the
polynomial is not specified
um but if you look at the proof you can
see that it's at least 12.
um so so this this is very good but it
doesn't give an explicit explicit uh
polynomial runtime and in fact it's
interesting to see that uh on and PSY
wrote uh wrote a paper around the same
time published in soda where they
proposed Jordan normal form as an
unteatable Benchmark for proving that a
computational device has a lot of power
so as a proof of work so somehow this is
actually being viewed as a as a very
difficult computational problem uh which
which it is actually yeah at the time
okay so that's the prior work uh and so
the new theorem uh is theorem B which
says which is an explicit polynomial
runtime Bound for computing the Jordan
role form uh and so it says given an a
bit integer Matrix you can compute these
V Prime J Prime and V Prime inverse so
again we also want the inverse we
compute to approximate the true inverse
in this many bitter operations would
forward our Epsilon so it's roughly n to
the sixth bit operations for an N by n
Matrix
um and there's this dependence on the
number of bits of the Matrix as well
so I won't tell you exactly what the
algorithm is it's not very complicated
it you know it combines some results
from the symbolic computation Community
with some other some numerical uh ideas
uh but I'll tell you what the key
structural Lemma and the proof is
and and the key thing that needs to be
proven is that
um if you have an integer Matrix a
then there is always a Jordan normal
form
for in which the similarity is well
conditioned as a function of the number
of bits of the input and the dimension n
so the statement is given any integer
Matrix and a with a bit entries
uh there is a factory general form with
a condition number of this similarity V
is bounded by exponential in a n cubed
so I mean some plus bound has to exist
right the number of
and bind matrices with a bit entries is
finite and so there's some bound on this
condition number and this is saying that
this is what this bond is foreign
so so roughly speaking the reason this
is relevant is that uh if you have a
matrix with a bounded condition number
then there are results saying that you
can store and manipulate it using
roughly log of that condition number of
bits of precision in particular there's
a very nice result of storage on
inverting Matrix inverting integer
matrices or rational matrices of bounded
uh condition number and so with once we
have this condition number bound these
type of results tell us that we can
manipulate these matrices in using a and
Cube bits of precision and this n to the
6A roughly is n to the is n cubed times
n to the 3A
uh for you know inverting such matrices
and so on
okay so let me now tell you the proof of
this key condition number estimate
so this is the key level given an
integer Matrix a there's a factorization
uh there's a Jordan normal form where
the similarity has condition number at
most exponentially and Cubed and as
proof combines some both symbolic and
numerical techniques
and it doesn't it it's it doesn't do
anything that fantastically new it just
combines techniques from a bunch of
different areas
okay so we have this Matrix a integer
Matrix and we want to bound the
condition number of this V so the first
step
is to appeal to a result of guys brecht
and store Johan
from 2002
which says that any integer Matrix is is
a similar to a companion Matrix this is
a forbidius canonical form I mentioned
earlier
with with some control on the number of
bits in this for Venus canonical form
okay so if a if a has little a bits then
it can be written as FCF inverse where C
is a companion Matrix f is invertible
and F has a N squared bit entries and C
has a n bit entries so the the added
thing here is control on the entries or
the bit length of the entries and they
prove this via fairly complicated
algorithm actually
so that's the first step so you write a
the forbinus canonical form with
controlled buildling
okay the
the second step is now to try to compute
the Jordan is to compute the Jordan
normal form of the companion Matrix and
this is something for which explicit
formulas are known so companion Matrix
is a very structured type of Matrix and
there's a result of brand from 1964
which says that if you have a companion
matrix it's stored in normal form uh is
very explicit in particular the
similarity is something called the
confluent van dermond Matrix in the
roots of the companion Matrix so namely
in the in the eigenvalues of The Matrix
and this I won't tell you exactly what a
confluent random Matrix is it's
something like a vandermond matrix the
entries are explicit nice polynomials
and so and so what this means is
um is that I have some kind of very good
structure for the uh for the Jordan
normal form of the companion Matrix
so now it would be nice if I could bound
the condition number of this similarity
u in the Jordan normal form of C because
then I could push that back to get some
control on the the
um similarity for the Jordan normal form
of a
so how do I do that well there's a
result of a tank off from 2012.
which says that if you have a confluent
vandermond matrix as we do in this
situation with the companion Matrix then
uh the norm of its inverse or actually
even it's its condition number is
bounded by um
uh well okay so the norm of this inverse
is bounded by a function of the minimum
eigenvalue gap of the Matrix so this is
kind of interesting it's saying that the
condition number of the Matrix of
generalized eigenvectors actually the
norm of the inverse can be bounded
purely in terms of the gaps between the
eigenvalues so this companion Matrix has
well spaced eigenvalues this similarity
U will be will be well conditioned
yeah so now this reduces our problem to
bounding eigenvalue gaps of this
companion Matrix C that we obtained from
a
now we know that c has a n Bits from the
first result right
and so that allows us to use a result of
minority from 1964 which says if you
have any polynomial with integer entries
then the minimum gap between distinct
roots of that polynomial
is at least exponential in minus a n
where a is the number of bits of the
coefficients of the polynomial
so how do we apply this in our setting
well our
um
our polynomial C is just a
characteristic polymer of the companion
Matrix
and uh the coefficients of that
polynomial are just entries of the
companion Matrix so they have bit length
at most a n
and so applying this Lemma it means that
the minimum gap between distinct routes
of these companion matrices at least
exponential and minus N squared
and now when we plug that into the
condition number bound from step three
when we plug this Gap bound into the
above we get that the condition number
of the similarity u in the Jordan normal
form of C is it has condition number at
most exponential a and Cubed
foreign ly we just combine all these
things we use the fact that the norm of
the inverse of an invertible Matrix with
a bit entries is at most exponential a n
roughly so I'm ignoring okay I'm
ignoring some some lower order terms
here
yeah there are constants and some log
factors everywhere that I've been
growing
um
so then that implies that well I know
that the condition number of U is at
most exponential a n cubed by this Gap
argument I know that the condition
number of f is at most exponential a n
cubed because it's an A N squared bit
invertible integer Matrix so if I
combine both of these things I get the
condition number of V is also at most
exponential some constant times n cubed
and that's the proof of the key level
and the interesting thing is you can't
really do this if you use purely
analytic techniques or purely symbolic
techniques you kind of need both
so that completes the proof of the uh
the key Lemma which then completes the
proof of this theorem
which then is used to give the proof of
this polynomial algorithm for computing
the spectral factorization of a matrix
polynomial
so that's it let me end with some open
questions so there are lots of open
questions so one is I don't know if this
n to the 6 is tight for Jordan normal
form it can be improved to enter the
Omega plus three but I don't know if
that's tight
so one question is what is actually the
bit complexity of Jordan normal form
it's a very fundamental problem would be
nice to know what the right answer is
and
uh that's a computational question the
key structural question that underlies
this is this condition number bound so I
don't know if this exponential a and
Cubed is tight and so the structural
question is given an integer Matrix how
large can the
um condition number of the similarity B
could it be improved to exponential A N
squared I know it cannot be improved
beyond that
another related family of questions is
about diagonalization so what is a bit
complexity of diagonalizing a
diagonalizable matrix diagnosable
integer Matrix and this is this is not
known so we know that for backward error
which is a notion of error and
scientific Computing it's nearly matrix
multiplication time but we don't know
for forward error and so you can ask
this question both for General
diagonizable matrices or for symmetric
diagonalizable matrices the matrices
that we see all the time and we don't
know what is the complexity of computing
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors with
forward error of a symmetric
integer Matrix and again the key
structural question that underlies this
is some kind of question about
conditioning and eigenvalue gaps so a
very common tutorial question that would
allow you to make progress on this
question is given a symmetric n by an
integer Matrix how close can two of its
distinct eigenvalues be
we don't know the answer to this so the
best lower bound is exponential and
minus N squared the best upper bound is
exponential and minus a n log n and
there's a huge gap between those I
should mention that the symmetric is
very important so recently in this work
with Abrams land on farmersheim we
showed that if you have a non-symmetric
integer Matrix then indeed you can have
two eigenvalues that are exponential
minus a N squared close
and then finally there's a question of
improving the running time for spectral
factorization itself so we gave some
algorithm that reduces it to your normal
form that's probably it may not be the
fastest algorithm you know maybe
analysis of the semi-definite
programming algorithm give a better
bound
Etc and then finally can we get an
algorithmic health and vinikov's Theorem
in geometry of polynomials out of this
so uh yeah that's it thank you